there's a great story of two two
lumberjacks where every morning they
start chopping wood at the same time
and every day they stop chopping wood at
the same time and every day one of the
lumberjacks disappears for about an hour
in the middle of the day
and every day he chops more wood than
the other guy and this goes on for
months
and eventually the one who works all day
he says i don't understand
every day we start at the same time
every day we stop at the same time
every day you disappear for about an
hour in the middle of the day
and every day you chop more wood than me
where do you go for that hour
and the other lumberjack looks up and
goes oh i'll go home and sharpen my axe
you know that that if you if you take an
infinite mindset it's not about how much
you can get done each day
it's how much you can get done over the
course of a career over the course of a
lifetime and
and you you got to take vacations which
means you turn off your email and you
turn off your phone and you do not
connect to the office
you know go sharpen your acts like you
do you take a friday afternoon off
you know we have something called do
they days in our company
where uh um where it's
you wake up in the morning and you just
can't do it
and it's not like asking you know it's
not like vacation days where you plan
ahead and it's not like sick days
you know where you're you're actually
sick like you're not sick
you just you just don't want to do it or
i'm just not feeling it you're just not
feeling it and you just you can't do it
and you do responsibly you can't leave
your team in the lurch obviously
you know we you have to exercise um
responsible freedom
but we give people an opportunity
instead of lying and pretending that
they have a stomach bug
um because they just can't face the day
that they can just call up and say i'm
taking a duvet day and everybody goes go
go we got you you know go
you